I have a visual on them
at the front
with the rifle
newly released video shows what led up
to a deadly shooting in New Jersey after
a suspect pointed an AK-47 at officers
he's down he put the rifle at us
he's down the New Jersey Office of the
Attorney General released the video in
the past week stemming from an incident
on January 22nd in Deptford New Jersey
that's where multiple 9-1-1 calls came
in for a man acting erratically
911 where's your emergency
went down the street and just smacked
the car and I'm really nervous right now
and I'm right next to my house caller
said the man identified as 55 year old
Daniel Nevis was driving a black jeep
they also said he may be having a mental
health crisis
well you said you think having like a
mental breakdown or something like that
another caller reported the man had a
weapon how do you know he has a gun
is it a black Key by chance
yeah what kind of uh what did it look
like was it hang on pistol rifle or
um
meanwhile surveillance video caught
Nevis ramming his Jeep into a parked
vehicle and later yelling
[Music]
9-1-1 callers tell dispatch Nevis isn't
making sense
at one point Nevis walks toward the home
on Fox Run Road with the gun in his hand
[Music]
traffic bucket
let's go when another car approaches the
driveway Nevis yells at the driver
a caller eventually reports Nevis
approaching the house
where are the cops at they're outside
they're outside right meanwhile officers
from the Deptford Police Department
respond to the scene this ain't my first
time responding to a man with AK-47 call
all right
we're gonna be all right
take deep breaths
calm your heart rate down when officers
arrive on the scene they make their way
through some nearby brush to get a
better look at Nevis I don't know I
don't I lost I don't see him yeah
there's Big Trees here's the trees as
cover yeah where's yeah
he's somewhere in here
officials can be heard calling for Nevis
asking him to move away from the house
Daniel
go that way bud
go that way
go away
go over there as this is happening other
officers make sure they have the correct
description of the suspect description
she uh is recording is a white male he's
got black joggers on the black T-shirt
eventually Nevis points his weapon at
officers that's when officer Luke Ivey
opens fire I have a visual on him
at the front
with the rifle
that's hard shots fired he's down he put
the rifle at us
he's down
okay you saw it right yeah
Nevis was pronounced dead on the scene
at 1 55 PM about 20 minutes after the
shooting unfolded investigators later
recovered his weapon the deadly shooting
is still under investigation by the
Attorney General's office reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie